- Your weapons will now be piut
through a series
of three tests.
Up first, kill test.
Doug?
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I'll take your
[inaudible] design
and deliver thrusts and
slashes on this deer carcass.
Nick, you're up
first, you ready?
Guess so.
Let's do this.
Yeah, I'm feeling pretty good.
I'm just excited to see
what's gonna happen.
I'm hoping this is the
only big, dead animal
I have to deal with today.
[intense music]
First up.
Right here on your edge,
it picked up a chip.
On the other side of
this, you can feel
where the edge also rolled.
But, this weapon is sharp.
On the initial thrust,
it's got a geometry
right there to penetrate
deep into the carcass.
Your edge right here--
on slashing, it lacerated
easily on the side
of this deer carcass.
On the third cut, the weight
of this weapon is so balanced.
It's easy to lacerate
all the way through.
Your weapon will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Alex, your turn.
His seems to do really well.
It stabs right through,
it slashes real nicely,
so I'm excited to
see what mine does.
And like, a little bit,
like, throw-y up-y like,
to right there.
[intense music]
All right, Alex.
Your tip is sharp enough to
lacerate all the way through.
On the slash of this edge, it's
lacerated easily on the side
rib of this particular carcass.
On the wide swing, it did
break half of the spine off.
It is, as you can see, a
little bit on the wider side.
And with the heavy
weapon like this,
a wide handle can make
it hard to control.
But the most important
thing, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen,
it's time for the strength
test the pike chop.
That was intense.
I wasn't ready for that.
So to test the strength and
durability of your weapons,
including the hook on
the back, I'll be pushing
these pikes up into
position then chopping
at them with the blades.
All right Nick, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[intense music]
(WHISPERING) I'd say
that's pretty good.
All right.
So, Nick, it doesn't look
like your weapon took
any more damage to the edge.
The weight of your blade
is very nicely balanced.
The good design--
definitely a strong blade.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Alex, you ready?
Yes, sir.
I'm in and out of "I
think I got this" too "I
have no idea what's
going to happen" so, I
still feel I got a good shot.
I think I'm still
in the running.
(WHISPERING) Kick ass.
Don't break it.
Be nice.
[intense music]
That was brutal, dude.
First off, your blade
did take some damage, here.
There are very small
chips and rolls.
Your flanges here
are just wide enough
that when I pushed
forward, I managed
to grab two rows
of pikes and pushed
them back at the same time.
Balance is nice on it.
The shaft is pretty wide.
It's not too big, but it's right
on the outside edge of what's
comfortable for my hand.
But everything held
up, everything's solid.
Thank you.
Because Alex's blade
picked a couple of chips up,
we're really even closer
to even at this point.
Nick.
Alex.
You've both done an
incredible amount of work
on your finale weapons.
However, there can only be
one "Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is--
[tense music]
Nick.
Congratulations, you are our
next "Forged in Fire" champion.
Alex, unfortunately your
weapon didn't make the cut.
David Baker's gonna
to tell you why.
Alex, you both brought
us beautiful weapons.
Both your weapons took damage.
Really came down to that large
handle and the forward weight,
and it's that final point
that sending you home.
Alex, please
surrender your blade.
So, the final judgment.
I am not the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
It was definitely a long
road to get all the way here,
and it is disappointing.
But Nick won.
He absolutely killed it.
He made a great weapon.
I'm super happy for him.
It was a tight race, so.
It's been a fun experience, but
it's since back to work now.